[موسيقى]
مرحبا نجاح كبير اثاره فيه الخلاط بمجرد
عرضه على احدى المنصات حيث صعد سريعا الى
قائمه الاعلى مشاهده في التطبيق وليس في
السعوديه فقط اتسجل اكثر من واحد ونصف
مليون ساعه مشاهده وذلك في الاسبوع الاول
من عرضه ويعتبر الخلاط بلس اول انتاج
السينمائي لمنصه نتفليكس في السعوديه
بالتعاون مع شركه التلفاز 11 وعرض لاول
مره ضمن فعاليات الدوره الثانيه ومهرجان
البحر الاحمر السينمائي في ديسمبر الماضي
الفيلم مستوحى من السلسله الشهيره الخلاط
ويحكي العمل اربع مصائب اجتماعيه مترابطه
منها صديقي يعود الى مغسله موتى لدفن السر
وسط شك زوجه الميت وقمت تبحث عن زوجها
ليبحث عن ابنه في ملهالي طبعا الفيل يشارك
في بطولته العديد من نجوم الخلاط محمد
الدوخي ابراهيم الخير الله عبد العزيز
الشهري ابراهيم الحجاج صهيب قدس فهد
البتيري وزياد العمري واسماعيل الحسن وهو
من اخراج فهد العم
عجبني انه جميع الشخصيات في القصه تحتال
وبالتالي قدمت الحيله بانها جزء من حياه
اي انسان القصه الثانيه عجبني فيها هذا
التباين في الشخصيات وكمان هاي القصه فيها
قالب اثاره مبالغ فيه شوي وفي اجزاء خصوصا
مع الوصول للنهايه شعرت بانه لا زالت غير
مفهومه القصه الاخيره بتبني احداثها على
العيله اللي بيحكمها الاب وواقعيه هاي
الفكره بتخلي هاي النقطه اكثر ما عجبني في
القصه
[موسيقى]
استطاع فيلم التالي لايجاد للفنان بيومي
فؤاد او الفنان محمد ثروت انه يضع نفسه
ضمن قائمه الافلام الخمسه الاكثر اقبالا
في السعوديه وهو اجازه لم يستطع هنيدي حتى
ان يقترب منه نبيل الجميله اخصائي تجميل
واللي لم يدخل قوائم الافلام العشره
الاكثر اقبالا في السعوديه منذ بدايه عرضه
قبل اسابيع ولغايه اليوم بينما وفي مصر
اشارت مصادر صحفيه الى انه الفنان بيومي
فؤاد اصيب بصدمه بسبب الايرادات المتدنيه
للفيلم واللي حققها واصبحت يعني في اليوم
لا تتجاوز المئه الف جنيه
طب على فكره بقى انا حامل نعم يا اختي
[موسيقى]
مش عايزه اشوفكم تاني
[تصفيق]
بدل الفنان مع المنتج مقر تصوير مشاهدة في
مسلسل جعفر العمده واليقوم ببطولته الفنان
محمد رمضان والفنانه روبي ويناقش قضيه
المراه في المجتمع من خلال تولي سيده شابه
منصب عمده قريتها لتواجه كل تحديات الواقع
من جهه اخرى استطاع ادوارد انه يخطف
الانظار في عروض مسرحيه كازينو بديعه
واللي مستمره لغايه الان بعروض نهايه كل
اسبوع حيث تحتفي به الصحافه مع كل عرض
وتراه متالق على المسرح بعيدا عن الدراما
وهو ما جعل البعض يؤكد على انه التركيز
ادوارد والي لم يكن متوقعا كل هذا النجاح
سيصبح بعد الانتهاء من الموسم الرمضاني
علشان يغني يمثل كان يعني استاذ فريد
الاطرش استاذ محمد عبد الوهاب بيكتب لها
استاذ ابو السعود الابياري
بيعمل موجات عندها استاذ اسماعيل ياسين
يعني كان كان ملتقى الفن كله في كازينو
بديع
[موسيقى]
العمر ما بدا عرضه هيتواصل بالجريء بينما
قدمت خلاله ريهام عبد الغفور اداء
استثنائي بحسب ما وصفات جمهور على هاشتاق
العمل واختلفت اراء الجمهور بشان جراه
التناول وواقعيه القصه فيما اعتبر بعضهم
مسلسل غير تقليدي بكل المقاييس يعرض
المسلسل الذي يضم عدد كبير من نجوم
الدراما المصريه الى جوار الابطال على
منصه جاهد الرقميه اسبوعيا يوم الخميس
ويتصدر مسلسل ازمه منتصف العمر ترند منصه
شاهد بعد تصاعد الاحداث الكبير خلال
الاولى حلقاته من جهه اخرى ووسط النجاح
الكبير اللي حققوا العمل عبر بطل المسلسل
الفنان كريم فهمي عن تخوفه من انه يصرف
هذا النجاح الجمهور عن استقبال فيلم
الجديد ان لحبيبي واللي راح يبدا عرضه
اليوم في السينمات من بطولته وبطوله
الفداده ياسمين رئيس واخراج الفنان هادي
الباجوري
وهي بنت خالي وبس مش اكتر
[موسيقى]
في اول الطريق انا
ضربني عشان قلت لك انا عايزه مبروك يا عزه